protesters march through Nairobi to
demand justice after an electoral
official was murdered Christmas and OH
schooling has made some fear a repeat of
the violence that has marred Kenyan
elections in the past stabilizing and
seeing how elections are Christmas andis
family identified his corpse at the
morgue they couldn't believe the IT
manager was murdered the mourners at the
morgue included miss Anders co-workers
from the Electoral Commission there his
job was making sure no one could miss
uses technology to rig the presidential
elections on August the 8th the killing
and murder of our employee Christmas and
oh there's no doubt and mother I know
post-mortem will be done in my in our
mind as a commission the only issue is
who killed him and why it wasn't the
only violence in recent days Kenyan
Special Forces Fortin entry inside the
home of the deputy president it took the
soldiers nearly a day to subdue him and
one officer died in the assault it's
unclear how and why the man forced his
way in
but the shootout has further increased
political tensions with Kenyans voting
in just a week from now